[Música]
[Aplausos]
ay yang jing que verdaderamente pueda
decir yo nunca está en ninguna crisis yo
definitivamente no y creo que muy pocas
personas podrán decirlo porque la
palabra de moda hoy en día precisamente
es crisis estamos hablando de una crisis
de salud mundial crisis económicas
crisis políticas crisis ambientales
empresariales familiares y puedo seguir
personales verdaderamente estamos
viviendo constantemente en crisis
recuerdo perfectamente en unas
vacaciones cuando mi sobrinito de 4 años
llega y me dice tía tengo una crisis
existencial
lo vuelvo a ver extrañada y qué te pasa
y me dice es que todos nos vamos a morir
cuando me causó gracia y me causa susto
que un niño estuviera pensando eso pero
cuando lo reflexiono me doy cuenta que
así es como vivimos nosotros
constantemente pensando en situaciones
críticas que probablemente llegarán
dentro de muchos años
algunas que incluso no llegarán y otras
que cuando lleguen vamos a poder
solventarlas de una manera fácil
porque por naturaleza los seres humanos
estamos diseñados para sobrevivir a las
crisis y todo esto tiene origen en la
neurociencia nuestro cerebro manda
mensajes inmediatos a nuestro cuerpo
para activarnos para activar esos
impulsos hormonales y fisiológicos para
sobrevivir lo más común lo que
normalmente conocemos como ese impulso
de adrenalina que si de repente alguien
viene a atacar salimos corriendo
muchísimo más rápido de repente sale
fuerza sobrehumana para poder
defendernos y no sabemos cómo llegó y es
precisamente ese impulso que nos hace
estar constantemente en alerta y esto no
es que sea malo verdad el problema es
que si no logramos diferenciar una
crisis verdadera de situaciones por las
que nos estamos preocupando que no
necesariamente sean críticas llega el
momento en el que es sumamente cansado
nos afecta psicológicamente nos afecta
físicamente
de hecho más de 264 millones de personas
en el mundo sufren de ansiedad en este
momento porque estamos constantemente
pensando en esas cosas que nos pueden
pasar en esta vida
yo tengo 15 años de estar trabajando en
manejo de crisis empresariales a veces
mi vida comienza super fácil está
tranquila y libre mi agenda y de repente
tengo días llamadas perdidas de un
cliente que pasa están en crisis no
saben qué hacer y necesitan que
lleguemos a ayudarles cuando llegamos
todo el mundo está desesperado nadie
haya cómo solventar las cosas y es
interesante porque a veces hasta hemos
ensayado lo que va a pasar sabemos que
la crisis viene pero aún así no
encuentran qué hacer
y de hecho se debe a esos impulsos que
están en nuestro cuerpo que tienen
nuestro cuerpo en alerta que nos hacen
reaccionar y no necesariamente pensar
con claridad cómo vamos a manejar las
situaciones y esto es
totalmente normal
de hecho cuando llegamos nosotros de
repente se empieza a ver como esa luz al
final del túnel y en primer lugar es
porque nosotros somos externos a la
organización no nos está pasando a
nosotros la crisis es una situación que
le está pasando a ellos y por eso es que
ellos están con esas emociones al máximo
cuando llegamos nosotros que somos
externos y podemos verlo desde otra
óptica de repente se empiezan a ver las
cosas más claras
fresca en realidad esto de desesperarnos
y que nos afecten tanto las crisis es
totalmente natural yo les voy a contar
en mis inicios cuando tenía como unos
cuatro años de estar trabajando en el
mundo de asesoría para manejo de crisis
recuerdo que terminé totalmente quemada
con ataques de ansiedad terribles
teniendo que ir al psicólogo y tanto así
que empecé a odiar mi trabajo tanto así
que me fui del país porque ya no quería
saber absolutamente nada más de crisis
el problema fue que yo sentía que aunque
trataba de huir de las crisis las crisis
llegaban a mí y eso empezó a preocuparme
porque dije bueno es que yo de las
crisis realmente no voy a poder huir y
de hecho comencé a disfrutar las crisis
cuando me di cuenta que iban a llegar a
nuestra vida constantemente y que la
clave no estaba en huir sino que la
clave estaba verdaderamente en darle la
bienvenida sabiendo que las podíamos
solucionar y salir victoriosos de ese
tema
porque tengamos claro que no todo de las
crisis en negativo
generalmente son cambios que tienen
aspectos positivos en nuestra vida como
empresa recientemente en plena pandemia
decidimos hacer un estudio del bienestar
en los centroamericanos
y nos llevamos la sorpresa
de que por ejemplo las personas mayores
de 65 años habían incrementado su nivel
de bienestar durante la pandemia porque
habían podido tener contacto con
situaciones que no habían vivido como
poder hacer transacciones bancarias
digitales poder hacer videollamadas con
sus familiares cosas que ellos pensaron
que la tecnología no nos iba a alcanzar
en un a poder usar y se dieron cuenta
que la llegada de esta situación crítica
de la pandemia les permitió sentirse más
cómodos con algo nuevo que estaban
aprendiendo en el estudio nos revelaba
también por ejemplo que los padres de
familia sentían un mayor nivel de
bienestar porque ahora con el
teletrabajo en las casas podrían
compartir tiempos con sus hijos que
incluso algunas empresas habían
incrementado su nivel de fidelidad de
sus colaboradores porque habían manejado
bien la pandemia entonces el tema no
radica necesariamente en la crisis sino
en cómo la estamos viendo y cómo vamos a
llegar a manejarla es un poco la óptica
y la actitud que estamos poniendo en la
crisis dejar de tenerle miedo y querer
bien
y más bien decirles aquí estoy porque te
puedo solventar y voy a aprender algo
verdaderamente
y es que es bien interesante porque
hemos vivido crisis toda la vida a veces
sin saberlo incluso crisis desde bebés
aquel momento en el que estamos llorando
y queremos comunicarnos con nuestro papá
y no saben que tenemos hambre frío sueño
que creando parece bebé es una crisis de
repente las caídas que tenemos al
aprender a caminar el famoso estudio
aprender a leer las tablas las famosas
crisis amorosas en la adolescencia tanta
crisis que hemos vivido en la vida que
ahora nos parecen visibles o incluso las
podemos minimizar pero en su momento
fueron situaciones verdaderamente
complejas veíamos gigantes y si logramos
salir de esas situaciones eso quiere
decir que podemos salir de las
situaciones críticas que estamos
viviendo en este momento y de las que
van a venir porque créanme que vendrán
más situaciones críticas
ay me gusta explicarlo un poco con el
triángulo dramático de karma que
contempla tres factores en primer lugar
el perseguidor vamos a llamarlo como el
villano
en segundo lugar la víctima y en tercer
lugar el salvador que a mí me gusta
llamarlo el superhéroe
generalmente cuando entramos en una
situación crítica lo que sucede es que
inmediatamente entramos en el papel de
la víctima y empezamos a sentirnos mal
nos empezamos a sentir afectados y llega
un momento en que decidimos a lo mejor
vivir la crisis sin saber cómo
solucionarlo pero qué pasa si decidimos
tomar nosotros el papel del superhéroe
qué pasa si en el momento que llega la
crisis yo digo bueno aquí viene la
situación yo puedo salir de esta y yo he
decidido salir de ésta yo cambio de
actitud y comienzo a trabajar con ella y
es que porque como les digo nosotros
estamos diseñados para salir de las
crisis por naturaleza
a mí me gusta mucho hacer la relación
comparativa entre estas crisis
empresariales que viví durante todos
estos años con las crisis personales y
traer ese paralelo que nos ayude un poco
a enfrentarlas de una mejor manera
lo primero que yo siempre le digo a los
clientes número uno separé las acciones
de las emociones separen la situación
crítica de como usted se siente
generalmente cuando nos preguntan
qué te pasa nosotros decimos me siento
mal o sea no hacemos referencia a lo que
está pasando realmente sino como
nosotros nos sentimos ante esa situación
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
darle un nombre la crisis me está
pasando tal cosa si yo no reconozco que
estoy en un momento difícil y que puedo
hacer algo para salir de eso de ese
momento va a ser muy complicado
realmente poder sobrellevar
el segundo elemento que a veces es un
poco tramposo y no nos gusta a todos es
vivir un día a la vez y se oye fácil
pero generalmente no nos gusta porque
cuando estamos en crisis lo que queremos
hacer es que la crisis termine lo más
rápido posible estamos decididos a que
se acabe lo más pronto posible el
problema es que hay elementos externos
en una situación crítica que nosotros no
necesariamente vamos a poder controlar y
como no los podemos controlar si
queremos que la crisis acabe en dos días
no pasa va haber otro nivel de
frustración porque no lo logramos
terminar en el tiempo que esperábamos
hay que estar conscientes de que van a
haber días más difíciles que otros
dentro de una crisis y que van a haber
crisis que van a ser más largas que
otras de hecho hay algunas que a lo
mejor estamos conscientes que van a
pasar meses o años para que los podamos
solventar pero si estamos conscientes de
que hay que sobrevivir cada día de la
mejor manera tratando de luchar y hacer
nuestros propios héroes en esta crisis
el panorama va a cambiar
el tercer elemento que creo que también
es súper importante pero al mismo tiempo
muy difícil cuando estamos en crisis es
no pensar demás las cosas
cuando trabajamos las crisis
empresariales
generalmente tenemos este cuarto de
crisis le llamamos el cuartel de crisis
y nos encerramos y todos empezamos a
trabajar y a pensar 24 horas en la
situación crítica
pero de repente como que uno ya no se
encuentra las soluciones y es
precisamente porque estamos con esos
niveles de emoción al máximo con esa
ansiedad con todas esas hormonas activas
todos esos impulsos que no nos dejan
pensar con claridad derrepente hacemos
una pausa alguien va por un café va al
baño y de repente vienes con la solución
no se les ha pasado pero yo muy buenas
ideas se me ha ocurrido en la ducha o se
me han ocurrido cocinando en otros
lugares no necesariamente pensando en la
crisis y es por eso porque hay que dejar
descansar un poco la situación crítica y
poder pensar en otras cosas que nos den
una mayor claridad
y el último punto que también para
algunas personas es bastante complejo es
el famoso trabajo en equipo o la
creación de un comité de crisis
cuando estamos en crisis generalmente no
le queremos contar a nadie lo que nos
está pasando y tienen lógica porque a
veces cuando le contamos a la gente las
cosas todo el mundo tiene una opinión y
una mala intención la gente
verdaderamente nos quiere ayudar pero al
tener todo el mundo una opinión y no
quiere decir cosas favorables hay cosas
que incluso ya intentamos o sabemos que
no podemos intentar o sabemos que no
funcionan y sentimos que perdemos tiempo
en toda esta plática constante de la
crisis lo mismo pasa a nivel empresarial
yo no le digo que le contemos la crisis
a todo el mundo pero sí hay que contar
en la crisis a nuestro propio comité de
crisis y el comité de crisis no se debe
crear en un momento de crisis las
empresas no lo hacen así lo crean en un
momento de tranquilidad porque tenemos
que identificar a esas personas clave en
nuestra vida que nos van a poder ayudar
a solventar la situación
personas que van a pensar de una manera
más tranquila recordemos que al ser
externos no van a tener esos niveles por
los cielos densidad que tenemos nosotros
durante la situación crítica esta gente
va a poder llegar y va a poder ayudarnos
verdaderamente solventarla
en realidad yo no creo que haya una
receta para sobrevivir a las crisis cada
crisis va a ser diferente y cada uno de
nosotros va a tener la posibilidad de
llevarla de la mejor manera posible pero
sí creo que es importante que estemos
dispuestos a dar la bienvenida a esta
crisis y estar conscientes que vamos a
salir fortalecidos de cada una de esas
situaciones como hemos salido
fortalecidos de situaciones previas
pensemos un poco en las obras de arte
las obras de arte con hierro son
expuestas a más de 1200 grados
centígrados y golpes
las obras en vidrio son expuestas a más
de 500 grados pero cuál es el resultado
son procesos difíciles que dan
resultados extraordinarios igual serán
las crisis de cada uno de nosotros
procesos difíciles con resultados
extraordinarios
[Música]